This episode is sponsored by (LastPass)
Whether your dilemma is forgetting your keys,
Or trying to fill the information in your mind before the test,
Sometimes we need to have our mind less forgotten,
So, scientifically, how can memory be improved?
First you have to go to a gym,
But excuse yourself, you can not escape the cardio exercises.
Magnetic resonance imaging results indicate that aerobic exercises such as running ...
Improve the performance of memory functions by increasing blood flow in parts of the "hippocampus" in the brain
The importance of this is that the "Hippocampus" part of the brain,
It is an important part of learning and remembering,
But decreases annually by 1 to 2 in late puberty.
Aerobic exercise is therefore an effective way to combat memory aging.
After exercise and a snack,
After a meal, both high glucose and insulin work on
Promote learning new information,
Glucose and insulin are important elements
In support of short- to long-term memory transformation,
This may be due to the "hippocampus" enhanced by insulin receptors.
Try adding berries to your rich meal
Studies show that participants who were given updated berries
Have become more able to remember past events.
The berries contain flavonoids, which protect neurons
Improves their functions and stimulates their regeneration.
Be sure to communicate with others,
Where scientists linked successful personal relationships with good memory,
In 2017 a study showed that adults aged 80 and over
And who have happier relationships in their old age
They have mental abilities equal to those aged 50 and 60.
Other studies have shown that people interview
May protect against weak memory common in mental illness
Scientists believe that our friends produce social pressure.
Which makes us care about ourselves
It makes you do simple things directly or otherwise as a doctor visit.
Social interaction makes you face complex intellectual challenges that stimulate the mind.
Are not you friends?
Embrace your friends right away because they stimulate your memory.
If you really want to stimulate your memory
You can be the hero of remembering.
Champions can remember to arrange a set of cards in 30 seconds.
High memory skills are not attributed to the different structural structure of the body,
Which means you can accomplish such mental activities ..
Through intensive practice.
One study showed that after 6 weeks ..
Consisting of a training program for 30 minutes a day,
Ordinary people showed the results of neural connections similar to those of memory reminders.
When they gave a list of 72 words
Instead of remembering 26-32 words, they could remember more than 60 words.
If you are afraid to forget your lecture tomorrow
do not worry...
Because research suggests that a high degree of anxiety helps you remember details
During disturbing events, different hormones such as cortisol work
Stimulates the mind to form long-term memory.
Perhaps this enables us to deal with disturbing situations and change our actions accordingly,
This does not mean, that during difficult times
We will become better at remembering things,
Because intense anxiety weakens memory.
It is therefore important to balance the panic and the lack of it to the benefit of your mind.
Translation: team translate @autrjim